(dramatic music)
- In December of last year,
doctors in Wuhan, China had
a mystery on their hands.
People in the region were coming down
with an unusual pneumonia.
It's cold and flu season,
but these people didn't have either.
Doctors quickly realized it
might be something entirely new.
- Medical nightmare, the
coronavirus outbreak.
- Never seen before coronavirus.
- The number of confirmed
cases in China keeps soaring.
- [Newscaster] Already 45 cases.
- [Broadcaster] 200 Cases.
- [Female Broadcaster] There more than
6,000 confirmed cases.
- But so far, this outbreak
has gone differently
from others in the past.
Thanks to the latest in biotechnology,
scientists have been able
to unravel the mystery
at remarkable speed.
They're revealing the
biology of the new virus
more quickly than ever before.
And they're hoping it's fast enough
to help drive back the disease outbreak.
Chinese officials told the
World Health Organization
that it had an outbreak
of some kind of virus
on December 31st.
By January 7th, Chinese
scientists figured out
that the virus was a Coronavirus.
That's from the same
family of viruses as SARS
which emerged in China in 2002
and MERS which infected people
in the Middle East in 2012.
The next step in
understanding the new virus
was sequencing its genome.
Figuring out the unique
order of nucleotides,
genetic building blocks that make it up.
The new coronavirus
genome looks like this.
It's just under 30,000 bases long.
The coronavirus is made of a type
of genetic material called RNA.
But, scientists convert it
to the more recognizable DNA
to make it easier to study.
That's what you're seeing here.
By January, 13, less than a
week after it was identified,
scientists in Shanghai had knocked out
the entire genetic
sequence of a virus sample
collected from a patient.
Compared though with the SARS virus,
which started infecting
people in November 2002;
it took until April 2003 before that virus
was sequenced in its entirety.
And at this point,
we don't just have one genetic sequence
for the new coronavirus.
Scientists have collected
and sequenced nearly
two dozen samples of the virus,
collected from different patients.
Researchers say the speed
has been unprecedented.
A lot of important things become possible
once experts have this
full sequence of the virus.
Notably, that blueprint can
end up in a place like this.
- Yeah, this is the exact typical,
all that we have is a
bunch of A, C, G and T.
And for us and our machine
we can print anything.
So if you want hemoglobin
today, we can print hemoglobin.
If you want chicken DNA,
if you want coronavirus DNA, we can do it.
- Twist Bioscience is a biotech company
in south San Francisco that
builds custom DNA to order.
As the coronavirus outbreak progresses,
scientists around the world
are turning to companies
like Twist to build copies of
viral genes for urgent study.
And they're sending in lots of orders.
- We expected that there would be
a number of demands for
variants of the coronavirus
to help in that discovery of drugs,
vaccines, and diagnostic kits.
And, whatever comes from the web tonight,
we'll start making tomorrow.
- Custom built DNA has been
around since the 1980s,
but the technology has
gotten dramatically cheaper
and easier since then.
So researchers today have a lot more DNA
at their disposal than they did during
the SARs or MERS outbreaks.
- [Emily] If you go back to 2000,
it would take $10.00 to
make one base of DNA.
In 2010, it will make
$1.00, so ten times more.
And today, it's $00.09 per base,
so again, ten times more.
- That's important, because
this kind of research
requires a lot of trial and error.
So the more copies of a gene
scientists have, the better.
- So it's biology.
And in biology it almost
never works on the first time.
You have to take a lot of
shots on goals to get there.
We give people the opportunity
to take more shots on goals faster.
And that way they can get
to that answer faster.
- There's a few things scientists
do with this genetic material.
It can help create tests
to screen patients for the virus.
It can help researchers understand
how the virus works and what
it does to cells in the body.
And crucially, it could be used
in the development of vaccines.
One important note,
even though companies like
Twist are churning out
copies of the coronavirus genome,
there's no concern they'll
accidentally start an epidemic.
They're not actually making the virus.
- I think one thing that
people should remember
is that nature is the
biggest bio-terrorist.
You know, nature wants to kill you,
and that's what happens
with the coronavirus.
So, the virus is out there.
The sequence is out there.
So, we are not creating more virus.
We are making fragments
of the virus to research
in order to enable them
to find tools to detect it
and tools to fight it.
(dramatic music)
- The coronavirus is
still a fast developing
public health crisis.
It'll be awhile before we fully
understand its health impact.
And longer still, before
there are treatments
or vaccines available to fight it.
But, thanks to the progress in DNA tech,
we have a greater head
start than ever before.
Thanks so much for watching.
If you're interested in learning more about the coronavirus, check out theverge.com for the latest news on the ongoing outbreak.